foreign
good morning time being nearly 10
o'clock we will open up the public
hearing on House Bill 25 is amended and
making Appropriations for the Capital
Improvements and uh if there's anyone
else here today that would like to speak
to this subject just please fill out a
pink card pass it along and it'll come
up here is how we conduct our business
um our first speaker is missing part of
his name on here it'd be the
representative
The Honorable John Graham former
chairman please come forward John
Abraham John Abraham hey Graham yes
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee
um it is a honor to be here in front of
this August committee and I did not make
the clerk's job easier by providing
written testimony
um but I did want to talk about a couple
of things on the capital budget uh this
is the 12th one I've seen
um
and believe it or not I think some of
the veteran members will be able to tell
you that this one is easier than others
not easy but easier you have been
provided well top of mind hopefully
you've seen it a four-page document of
of capital projects that were done with
arpa funds if those were not done they
would all be competing in this capital
budget for things like rooftop unit
Replacements at the Brown building
Supreme Court HVAC upgrades all of which
we've heard before in in these hearings
on the capital budget
that said
it is great that we have uh Barbara
funds that we did that with and in House
Bill 2 and separate bills
um there is a move to use some surplus
funds for things that
if we did not use them for example the
Senate has a bill on on replacing the
Tramway at
Cannon Mountain
there are monies for the legislative
parking garage and house bill 2. all of
which would be competing for say
or against Rockingham the Rochester
Court under
um Das so you're still going to have
some work to do because you're going to
have to do some horse trading
but I just wanted to point that out that
this is
um something that you need to pay
attention
now just because it happens to be at
House Bill 2 does not mean it's going to
stay there
um I I know when I was here last week
and
um the commissioner of Corrections and
her staff was talking about a total of
50 million dollars within House Bill 2
for
um planning and other
items at the Men's prison here in
Concord last Monday
division one of Finance stripped 40
million of that 50 million out of the
house bill to
um so I might suggest you put that 40
million into the capital budget but you
just need to know that we're kicking the
can further down the road on the Men's
prison unless the Senate unless the
house says something on the floor or the
Senate does something when they get
House Bill too
and the rule of thumb that we've used
before is something around 10 percent
for planning and if you're looking at
300 to 400 million dollars for a new
prison you're going to need that 40
million dollars to do some planning
um
that said you've heard a lot of agencies
come in and I've looked at the paperwork
and kind of watched online some of them
have been here for some of them that
the agencies have come in with
additional requests you need to look at
those closely
and while
the treasurer has given you a number
that you can use it has been my
experience that if you increase it by 10
15 million dollars
over the 130 or so that the governor is
suggesting it does not move the needle
on the data for debt ratio affordability
studies so you do have some
um room to to add some things and one of
the things I would strongly recommend
that we
um at not we that you add
to the capital budget is the winuscom
CTE
if you look at everything that the
Department of Education handed out to
you you will notice that
if you only do one CTE a year it takes
40 years to to get to the school again
if you do too it's only 20 years before
you uh revamp them
so we need to stay on a schedule of
doing tube or biennium and I think that
within this budget
and if uh representative Jack and crew
on Monday found any additional money
some of that can go to it
there is that but back to the agencies
coming in asking for additional things
you have to ask yourself is it a
a want or a true need the agency will
tell you it's a need every agency will
do that and if I was a commissioner of
any agency I'd come in to tell you the
same thing but at some point you have to
work through what can be afford what is
the highest priority not for that agency
but for the state and that cuts across
all of the agencies you know there there
are things that they've come in and
asked to have money repurposed or do
that because the federal government will
pay a chunk of it
um you have to ask yourself is that
Federal money guaranteed are we just
putting money up hoping that it's going
to come so
I wish you luck this afternoon or
whenever you start on your work sessions
it is always a
challenge to put it together and to come
out with a compromise as the chairman
said it is what the first meeting I
think when he started all these the goal
is and always has been for this
committee to present this capital budget
to the the house and have it go on a
Voice vote
and most year most biennium that's what
happens
because this committee does good work
and I expect that they will continue
that said Mr chair but I did not use the
whole 10 minutes I put down
but I would take any questions if
anybody has any
I don't see a lot of people
behind me talking thank you thank you
um
Mr Graham
um and I really appreciate the comments
for the committee are there questions of
our former chairman
foreign
yes please I'm sorry I can't see in the
light over there thank you chairman and
thank you I appreciate those words as
someone who's just new on the committee
to kind of get some uh perspective I
want to go back and just your your
comments about the prison a quick story
my grand uh great uh
was born with uh birth defects way back
a hundred years ago or so and she wound
up in Laconia
chained to a bed so my recollection of
the of how the state has funded for
things like people who are not who are
people who are marginalized I guess is
the word they use today is that we're
very much behind the eight ball so
that's that's my bias at this point so
I'd just like to get hear your opinion
about the uh the prison and the funding
port
thank you there is a definite need for a
replacement facility
um for the Men's prison
um I think many of the the veterans
members
um have been on tours of it where they
have tarps trying to keep the the runoff
water coming through the roof and
everything else off of the kitchen uh
and it it is not a good situation as you
heard from the commissioner and her
staff it is a six plus year process to
do that it took us almost that long to
do the women's prison in the same locale
the challenge will be to come up with
the money to do it
um
if I had the magic wand I'd give it to
you to tell you how to do it I don't it
it's going to be a challenge for
um the committee
and the legislature to figure out how to
fund that that said the reason we have a
new uh women's prison is because we lost
a lawsuit
and we had to build a replacement
I'm not sure we want to wait till we
lose a lawsuit on the Men's prison
um
I'm not saying that there is one but if
there is one we may end up spending more
than what we would envision
now one of the things that we lost the
lawsuit on and why it's in there is to
secure psychiatric unit is in the Men's
prison
um the goal would be in my estimation a
secure forensic hospital for those
people who are
not guilty by reason of insanity I think
that's the term but some of them are
dangerous people and they need to be
secured
there is proposals going around for
um
take your take your pick on how many
beds the new one will have and where it
will be both of those are up but we need
to do that
it is not a new problem with the Men's
prison
I know that a couple of members
um
last week
um were dismayed that it was going to be
as expensive and that it was that bad
it's been that bad most of the time I've
been here and I came up here in 2000 and
the situation has only gotten worse
we've never been able to find the money
we put Band-Aids on the problem just
like we've been doing with the stores uh
Street Garage for the legislature and we
finally found the will and the money to
build a new one hopefully
um
but it is something that is
going to have to get started this
biennium because if you Kick the Can
it's another two years before you even
start
and so I don't know what's going to
happen with with money in House Bill 2
either in the house or the Senate but is
something that I thought you all needed
to be cognizant of because the
commissioner of of Corrections did
mention it and talk about what she
wanted to do with it and that she wasn't
asking for it in in this budget so
there's there's that
thank you further questions
just a brief caption in something that I
was glancing at recently after I had
been at the Men's prison
but the the sentence that I remember was
that
in addition to other things whether
there's a it was lawsuit driven meaning
if something gets so bad there might be
a lawsuit to make you do something and
what jumped out at me was the fact that
a lawsuit maybe even a pending one is
also affects your bond rating also is
that an accurate statement in Europe I
would defer answering that question to
the state treasurer she is the expert on
bonds and bond rating anything I say
would be anecdotal so I just can't
answer that question but
having been around here for long enough
that when we lose lawsuits it usually
costs us more than if we're just done
the planning and and completed whatever
project it was
any further questions
I want to thank you for appearing and
you'll see with your time for
questioning you did far exceed 10
minutes so we thank you for the long
drive and being here in committee and
and assisting where you do thank you
um you're welcome and I
um thank the committee for allowing me
to speak and
best of luck sorting out all of the
requests and the rest it is always a
wonderful work in progress thank you Mr
are there others wishing to testify on
House Bill 25 that have not had a chance
I thought our representative was going
to speak all right
the gentleman walking in or is there a a
need to address House Bill 25 public
seeing no further
I will uh recess
um
this hearing for the next 10 minutes in
case someone else walks in for the
committee we will pick up on our
executive session of our four bills at
10 30.
I'm going to have to check and see if we
can discuss this before one o'clock
um we will make a we will discuss uh
Appropriations for the Capital
Improvements uh at one o'clock so we
will stand in recess for the next 10
minutes
foreign
last call is there anyone here that
wanted to uh speak on House Bill 25
hearing before we move on to other
business
with that I will uh call close to uh
public hearing on House Bill 25 a making
Appropriations for the cap of a budget
I would like to move to the executive
session
and we will start with House Bill 189
renaming a portion of Route 140 in
gilmington in honor of private first
class nics Nicholas conier I believe
um like to recognize uh represent Newman
so that that portion of Route 140 in
Billington can be named for PFC Nicholas
cornoyer
motion motion made by Newman seconded by
Milt
um discussion
I'd just like to note that the only
reason the committee has held on to this
uh bill for a number several weeks is
only that we were waiting for the letter
of confirmation from the selectman and
we have a letter here signed by the town
of gilmington board of Selectmen that
they were in favor of house bill 189. is
um yes please representative Newman
when I I read
what a little bit about um
private corn Oiler I was struck by the
fact that he was born in Concord and
then went to school in in
excuse me in Gilman 10 and then
graduated from the Guilford High School
but I was mostly impressed by comments
that I read about his stage from his
teachers and Friends
the teachers commented that
he had a true sense of right and wrong
and and that just that that impressed
them and that impressed me when I read
that about them unfortunately he was
only 25 when he was killed in Iraq but
one of his goals at an early age was to
join the Army and he did so he lived his
life and apparently he knew right from
wrong and followed that as his
his true north compass thank you thank
you representative any further uh
questions
uh seeing none the uh if you're in favor
of the motion of ought to pass on House
Bill 180 189 you'll signify by saying hi
if you were opposed it'll be nay
and with that the clerk will call the
roll
thank you Mr chair
representative Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative fadolfi is not here
representative bogert
yes
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar all right
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
representative
representative Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
representative
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey chairman votes High
the chair of the vote is 13-0
ought to pass
motion passes 13-0 thank you
Mr chairman do we I think we should put
this on a regular calendar just in case
the family is there oh without a doubt
thank you yeah because if put on consent
then we'd have to pick could probably do
it but it makes it
thank you representative it will stay on
the regular calendar
thank you
without objection we will move now to
House Bill 361 relative to peace
chairman recognize the vice chairman I
would move to retain house bill 361.
motion has been made to retain by
Cloutier House Bill 361 is there a
second
discussion
I um I will just make a couple comments
if I could when we read back to the
formation of Peace Development Authority
um it the mission number one was what
what was the benefit that would come out
of that Authority for the state number
one number two would be a regional and
then finally third is local
and
um the bill suggest uh changing the
membership and appointing and being the
speaker and then tying the speaker to
who
he could appoint that he or she
um
flies in the face of the original
mandate for the peace Authority which is
supposed to be State interest first and
it was tying the speaker to appointing
people only from towns that uh the two
towns that we're concerned the other the
other thing that some I sometimes I
forget over the years is that was a
that's a government facility that we
basically have a lease over
and we have to be cognant all the time
of um of the FAA and other obligations
we have there so we we we truly need to
think in more of a State Global position
than uh than just the local town so I if
if there is an interest to rework this
we will do that with the remainder of
oh
um
he was not here when I was put
up yeah so representative we we had
motion was made so we won't be calling
you to vote on this one because you
weren't in the room it's just a motion
to retain yep
all right so um
if you're in favor of the motion to
retain when the clerk calls the roll
signified by saying I if you're opposed
nay and when the clerk has an
opportunity we'll call the roll thank
you Mr chair representative Cloutier yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes
representative Edgar
all right
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes
representative Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey
aye
Mr chair of the motion retained passes
13-0
thank you
um there'll be no need for a report
um
the next uh next item on our exec list
is House Bill 480 relative the
intersection between route 302 and East
Conway Road in Conway
concerns are you proud of it
480.
yes Mr chair I move itl on House Bill
480. I second that motion motion made by
the clerk seconded by the Vice chairman
itl House Bill 480 relative the
intersection between route 302 and East
Conway Road
uh in Conway
um discussion
yes represent below
so just to clarify
um so we've heard that dot is planning
to build a larger roundabout than what
was originally proposed is that correct
that would be true that would be the
represent Faulkner I
my feeling is that uh
there's a process that the department
follows that you know starts with local
involvement
considers engineering design cost issues
that that's a process that we ought to
have some faith in and
I would say that it's
we shouldn't be involved in picking
details of design except under the most
extraordinary circumstances and I I
don't think that we have those here so
I'm I I don't think that I wouldn't want
to interpret this as our picking one one
solution versus another but rather a
statement that
we're staying out of it until unless
there's something
unsolvable that we have to get it uh get
involved in so
uh I don't think that
I mean I don't want to endorse one one
solution over another would rather let
the local process do that
thank you representative Faulkner very
well said almost sounds like a blurb
from where I'm sitting
but honestly thank you for holding up
the Integrity of the 10-year plan is
there anyone else that wishes to comment
seeing no further discussion if you're
in favor of the itl motion uh for House
Bill 480 relative the intersection
between route 302 and East Conway Road
in Conway you'll signify by saying I
when called if you were opposed Nay with
that when the clerk has a chance please
call the roll thank you Mr chair
representative Cloutier yes
skip representative representative
bogert
yes
representative
Jack yes representative Abbott
yes
representative Edgar
aye representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes
Peterson yes
representative vallone yes
representative Kaczynski where you hear
when the question was put
chairman McConkey chairman votes High
chair of the motion Ito carries 15-0
thank you motion carries
our last item is House Bill 511 FN
relative regular calendar regular
um last last item is House Bill 511 FN
relative to requiring the Department of
Transportation to do road maintenance
and repairs according to its complete
streets program
is there a motion
Mr chair
yes I've I most I vote itl
motion is made itl by the clerk and okay
I will cycle that motion Mr chairman
thank you representative Cloutier uh for
the second
Mr chairman yes I guess I I feel to
speak and I've done a lot of research
and you may have seen some of the I had
the researchers send on a uh uh there
was a committee that was set up I
believe you were on it representative
Mills and some other members who are no
longer represent a senator mirzell and
uh in 2016 and then I think she I think
it was actually then senator feltis who
was also on the committee at the time
and she and Senator Phelps has tried to
get a bill through that came out of it
but it was killed in the Senate but
getting back to this bill
I don't like this bill because of the
word requires town city state
departments the state institutions
because I'm not a constitutional lawyer
but I think it could fly in the face of
the New Hampshire Constitution's part
one article 28a of no unfunded
mandates uh and I think if if the
state's going to do it they would have
to pay for it oh
the other thing is I look at the revised
fiscal note dated I think there was a
fiscal and updated
January 30th the original Bill had one
dated
uh January 9th and I don't know if
there's much difference but it still
says expenditures
for fiscal year starting fiscal year
2024-25 26 Etc both state and local
indeterminable and that sort of scares
me I mean I think
if I'm going to do a state program
especially I'm going to want to know how
much it's going to cost and it's also
who knows what if it's you know if it's
mandated what would cost the cities and
towns
um and I still think it at the very
least until we fix our our situation
when our state's Highway fund we ought
to be careful about adding new programs
but I do want to make it clear to people
here that I have nothing against
complete streets as a concept uh and I
think several cities uh I don't I think
conquer did it but I can't swear it
since I I but I know the City of
Claremont my city sort of used some of
the concepts to revitalize its downtown
uh made it one way banned trucks and we
had to work they had to work with Dot
and I helped them do that rearrange the
whole truck route so there's no more
trucks going through Pleasant Street
where a lot of businesses are but we're
we're trying to revitalize the downtown
to make it more friendly to pedestrians
you know and add apartment buildings
small shops Etc because this is the way
we feel or the city feels the way to go
for our downtowns I don't mean to go on
and on but I think we use some of those
Concepts so I don't have anything
against it because I think the city
council did the right thing and they
were smart they waited until they had to
dig up all their sewer lines they had to
replace them anyway to save money so I
don't even know whether they got state
or federal aid
but the but the point point is the other
thing a top-down approach I'm concerned
about that especially now not only I
represent the City of Claremont but the
town of Croydon a very small town and
their needs may be different uh and I
and I've way back I used to represent
two other towns unity and lemster for a
while when I was a rep but again there
there are different needs
so I I don't know if I want to mandate
stuff that may be appropriate for a big
city like Claremont but not for a small
town like Croydon that's the way I look
at it
um so I I feel that this bill is not
ready for for prime time maybe there are
other ways to do it
but I think it's it's got to be more of
a maybe a pilot program maybe eight if a
community wants it but not it's it
sounds like to me this could mandate
every municipality to do things a
certain way which may be fine for big
cities but may not be fine for our
smaller committees thank you Mr chairman
I I um yes represent uh excuse me
represent Mills thank you Mr chair as a
member of that original study committee
I just want to assure everybody that
what we had found was that the dot
understands and completely tries to use
the complete streets program as a
guideline however it is not always
feasible or practical at that time in my
town of Derry we had a great example
we've got we've got a major it's a
highway it's a rural highway
intersection that had to be rebuilt
because of a line of sight and they were
going to put in a stoplight
and because of the fact that this uh
complete streets program was in effect
at the time the D.O.T was they thought
they were under a mandate that they had
to put in at that intersection they had
to widen it enough to put in a bicycle
lane going both ways that would
certainly end as soon as the widening of
this intersection was done so that they
thought why are we putting in a bicycle
lane that is going nowhere it ends
literally 100 feet on either side of
this um
intersection so they they explained to
us that they use it as a practical
guideline anytime they're rebuilding
something when they want to do uh exit
4A in Dairy they went to Dairy and found
out that their streets in downtown Dairy
aren't even wide enough
to try and put in this this complete
streets programs without knocking down
buildings so the D.O.T is very very
aware of the program when practical they
they try and utilize every concept of it
but to make this mandatory on everything
just makes no sense
thank you Mr chair any further
discussion
before we before we call the roll on
this I I do want to make mention of two
things number one the amount of time
that Roshan Mills had put into this
project prior to
um and the time that uh Vice chairman uh
Cloutier has put in to get you
background information on this I have
always been a fan I served on that that
I think that this is the right way to
engineer
roads when we can and we can afford
pedestrian bicycle movements and so
forth so but unfortunately I believe
this we don't have enough money now to
pay for what we have for roads and
bridges and we're not quite ready for
this so with that seeing no further
discussion if you're in favor
of the motion which is itl for House
Bill 511 FN relative to requiring the
Department of Transportation to do road
maintenance and repairs according to its
complete streets program if you're in
favor of the motion itl you would
signify by saying I if you're opposed
it'll be nay and the clerk will call the
roll
thank you Mr chair representative
Cloutier yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative Newton yeah
representative Kaczynski yes
representative bogert
yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes
representative Edgar all right
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes
representative Peterson
yes
representative vallone yes
representative Juris yes
chairman McConkey
aye
thank you
clerk the nice to see our numbers are
growing we picked up a couple here yes
and that's going to be on the regular
that concludes our our executive session
for today and I believe that concludes
all the bills other than House Bill 25
that have been before us
I um I appreciate the ability of the
committee to work together and and to
bring us to this point so I thank you
for that
um unfortunately I have a scheduling
debacle here that we will uh we will not
be able to discuss House Bill 25 until
one o'clock today so I sincerely
apologize for that and hoping that a
couple of the other members will have
time to shovel their way to Concord
before then so
um we will we will be in recess until uh
1 pm
my my
goal here is that we will open up House
Bill uh House Bill 25 and start running
down from the top to the bottom uh
finding areas that we can find agreement
on
areas that might need an amendment will
make mention of which will give Chris
time to do that Drafting and when we
start you will be uh you'll have a full
listing of monies that have lapsed and
other monies that this committee will
have available to us to uh reappropriate
for other projects so with that unless
you have questions for myself as the
chair we will be in recess till one
o'clock and I apologize for that
tomorrow
there you go
you know we only have one billion except
that that's going to that state on
foreign
good afternoon
um we now will start in on House Bill 25
is amended for the new members I know
we've highlighted this before but I
would like to go there one more time
um this this bill is our culmination of
what we are here to do next year we'll
be talking the 10-year plan
our intent is that we will go through
find agreement I think we'll have time
anyways then to talk about other items
into this budget uh Friday we're hoping
to come together and reach a consensus
if we can have any amendments drafted
that needed to be drafted with a goal of
Monday
reporting this out and if it doesn't
happen on Monday we we have time if
there's amendments and so forth for that
so I would like to recognize Christopher
Shea first
describe some of these documents in
front of you and if I could please
thank you Mr chair for the record
crochet from the LBA I passed out three
documents one before lunch and then two
after lunch the first document is House
Bill 25 compare report so it's a
spreadsheet report
that is all the information from the
bill itself just put in an Excel file
for you to follow along to make it a
little bit easier to look at the
projects as you as you are discussing
them
the long sheet that looks kind of
similar was just a way that I was trying
to compile all the agency asks
in one on one sheet so it's a two-sided
sheet
so if you get to administrative services
and you're having a conversation and
you're like I think they asked for
something at the haze and drive if you
look at that you'll see that they ask
for two chillers at a cost of three
hundred thousand dollars at Hazen Drive
on both those documents you have a
column B which is the fund
if it says BG that means general funds
that's bonding General if it says Bo
that's bonding other
so it would be a source of funds that
the agencies identified that would pay
for the project and then if it's Federal
you'll see an F
and then if it's Highway you would see
the last document I passed out was a
packet of six six pages it's um what I
would refer to as friendly amendments
with reps of McConkey and repsum Jack's
name on it some of these came about from
the lapse extension review some of it
was requested agencies made of this
committee when they were presenting
these requests are things such as
changing a project name or moving a
project from one agency to another none
of these projects or none of these
amendments impact the dollars per se
it's just changing the focus or the
scope of a project or again moving it
so that's all I had just just want to
make sure the members knew what was
before them as the representative Jack I
guess is going to present his um lapse
thank you
and if you can believe for a third time
I've lost that document which one you
don't have two of those that right there
do you John I don't but if you want I
can okay we'll just let's put there
oh right there thank you that's the one
found it for the third time
all right thank you representative Jack
would you please uh take us through the
uh the work your uh lapse committee had
performed for us please uh thank you Mr
chairman on Monday we held a
subcommittee work session we had seven
agents we did same time uh the same way
we do it every time the agencies that
have a small number we Handle by email
uh and ask them if their lapse
extensions are correct and the larger
agencies we have in to present uh I
passed out a report it's it's one page
double-sided
uh every time the the one one remark I
would make is there is at least twice as
much activity
on the lap subcommittee as there is in a
normal cycle that includes items where
the agency has decided that they can
lapse the funds they no longer need them
extended
uh so you'll see lines where we're going
to delete those lines and that frees up
funds that we can repurpose for another
project you'll see
items where we want to add that is
an item that the agency
has decided is not in House Bill 25 and
they need to extend the appropriation
the reason being if it's not in House
Bill 25 in the extension section the
funds will lapse on June 30th and they
can no longer expend them
on the project that they're appropriated
for so they could get in a situation
where they can't pay a bill on a
contract that they've already awarded
because the funds have lapsed and then
the other thing that we
that we take is information on when they
want to change the purpose of an
appropriation
uh for example
uh
fishing game
wanted to change they had an
appropriation that was applicable only
to the Powder Mill Hatchery and they
wanted to use some of the funds on other
hatcheries in the state so they asked us
if we would change the title of the
appropriation to include all of the work
that they wanted to do those are on the
back side
and you'll also find them
in the in the document that Mr Shea put
out for additional agency requests and
you'll find them in the in the amendment
packet so if there's any questions I'm
thank you are there any um there thank
you are there any questions for uh
representative Jack from the
seeing none um
yes please uh just to come in if I may
uh
I was privileged to be able to to be at
the committee meeting
and I want to tell you that the hard
work that Jack put into this was just
beyond incredible that uh how he ran the
meeting and how the information was
provided to someone as new as me I
deeply appreciated it
thank you representative for that I
would I would have come to the same
conclusion it was nice to hear a new
member and we did bring in two new
members specifically uh representative
Juris and yourself so that we could you
could be a part of that in the learning
process so it's invaluable
representative Jack has done this at
least two terms
so very thankful for that and and
um
we have this package of of uh the uh
unapproved amendments uh that uh
Mr Shea gave us I think we should take
these as a one by one tonight the intent
today is to do a number of straw polls
they're not binding we don't have to
record anything we just need to figure
out whether or not these will meet with
everybody's approval and that we can
move on to the next step
and get them finalized so that they've
become real amendments this entire
package that we got
has no change in any dollar figures
these are all these are all the
mechanical things that have to be done
for instance as representative Jack said
about the fishery
the changing the the title of it that
has to be a separate Amendment and
that's in this package so we'd like to
go through these one by one
seeing if they meet with everybody's
approval just do a straw poll on this
and that way we can that that way we've
got actual figures that we can move
ahead with if everybody understands that
any questions anybody have any questions
on that
Chris are you okay with our format of
doing this
I am and would you like me to walk the
committee through each of the Amendments
yes thank you to be my next guy my next
statement
so we'll start with Amendment 1003h
this was a request from administrative
Services it came to the capital budget
overview committee
um
last Friday I handed out a document
that same day to this full committee
where the request was to transfer a
project for the Philbrook sewer line
replacement
from Department of administrative
services to the Department of Health and
Human Services the reason for the
requested change is that building's use
has changed from being an office
building and is now a facility to house
individuals which is the under the
purview of Health and Human Services
it doesn't change the value of the
project or the process of the project
and I'll just keep moving forward unless
somebody wants to ask me a question
the next page is amendment
1009h it's a second request from the
Department of administrative services
this is a request that came in during
the lapse extension review I believe
but it's to rename a roof replacement
project
um from Peasley Wing to the North
Pavilion Wing the department of
administrative Services has determined
that the Peasley wing of the main
building is not
um salvageable and they have no
intention of continuing to put money
into it in fact at some point I think
there's some going to be an effort to
maybe remove that piece of the building
if if members have questions any of
these amendments please raise them as we
go through otherwise we will we will do
a straw poll at the end unless you want
to go individually yes representative
Jack thank you can I just make one this
is a little piece of inside baseball if
you look at line three you'll notice
we're amending the capital budget from
2017.
to amend the purpose in 2017
because that's what we have to do all go
all the way back to the original
appropriation and amend that and then
modify all the lapse extensions
so the part in line 12
uh
will will amend
the the lapse extension
to to the new language
that's absolutely correct so if you
actually look at line 13
um it reads
near the end as amended by this act so
that's basically we're going to refer to
the section 12 that amends the previous
chapter excuse me the previous uh
statute
okay
is everyone okay with the first two
please continue
moving to the third item which is one
zero zero four h that's a request from
The Fish and Game Commission
they had an appropriation for the Powder
Mill Fish Hatchery of 4.6 million
dollars
um
and I think I think the director might
have talked about it when he was here
but there were part of the reason for
that appropriation in the last capital
budget is that there were some
environmental issues and they were being
um
pressured to get some things completed
there
with the arpa money Fish and Game
Commission was provided another 58 I
think it's 58 million dollars of arpa
funds to renovate hatcheries Statewide
and they're in the process of putting
their Statewide plan together on how
they want to move forward with that so
their request was to add this money to
the money that they they have for arpa
and as they put their plan together and
determine how they want to handle the
hatcheries they'd be able to have a
approximately 62 million to almost 63
million dollars for that purpose
if we if we could pause here represent
Newton we had we had spoken earlier
about this project
yes address it yeah I have a concern
with this because of the way I read it
it's taking the four million 615
000 kind of moving it around out of the
Powder Mill Hatchery if we've got that
much money in there from Oppa where is
the urgency to take this for
0.615 million out when we were told to
get it in the first place how it was
urgent that we update the Powder Mill
Hatchery because of the affluent that is
going into the river causing algae
blooms that is then eventually that
river goes into one of usaki and I did
read something recently where the EPA is
getting even more stringent
with what's happening in that area so
why if there's that much other money
there why would we
direct this 4 million six hundred
fifteen thousand someplace else went as
far as I know nothing's been done there
to date
So based on the testimony from the
director
they're in the process of putting their
Statewide plan together for all the
hatcheries and they are still
identifying what purpose each Hatchery
will have and if it will stay the same
size be Consolidated down or maybe be
closed and move somewhere else
so that that was his testimony when he
was before this committee your concern
is that there there's already some
issues occurring there
um and you would like them to still have
you would like them to try to use this
money there first before they'd used it
anywhere else in the state to address
their problems what I'm hearing yeah
well again they when they came to us a
year or two ago the urgency was to do
something there
and the Powder Mill Hatchery has already
given the lot up they no longer raise
salmon there because of the effluent
that's going out and it doesn't make a
lot of sense because the Powder Mill
Hatchery used to get the salmon right
from Winnipesaukee which is a stone
throw away excuse me by mayor meeting
Lake which is a Stones throw away in the
Hatchery
serves most of the Seacoast with the
stocking program that they have and
what's unique about this Hatchery is
there's two inlets for the Hatchery out
of marinating Lake which is one of the
cleanest lakes in the state
and they can draw the water into the
Hatchery from the top of the lake when
the
temperature best suits raising of trout
and then in the summer months when it's
warmer they can draw the lake lake water
from a lower level where the water stays
cool so it's an ideal spot to do what
they've been doing obviously the Powder
Mill Hatchery has been in the in Warwick
since 46 I think
and man I I just don't think that if
they've got that much out of the money
58 million in apple money I'd like to
see this
4.615 million be directed to where we
directed it two years ago it doesn't
seem to me like if they had 58 million
and other changes to do they couldn't
cover it with the other money without
getting into this and I I really oppose
this because the part of my Hatchery I
took a long tour there and they have
cement troughs that are crumbling and
breaking apart
and it's just not it's got to be fixed
we need to keep this
resource it's an ideal place
and
the tourism that's generated tourism
doll is from the Fisheries is tremendous
and it's right in that area it's you got
Winnipesaukee meeting again all the I
think they go as far south as Hampton to
the Seacoast to stock trout so they
covered the Powder Mill Hatchery does a
lot for the state and man I just would
like to see them they came to also the
plan they're going to put in all new
instead of the symmetro office they were
going to be fiberglass it was going to
be updated and take care of the affluent
that was going uh the fish waste and
going down into the river and causing
algae bloom so again man I would hate to
see this if they've got 58 million
and beside this 4 million I'd like to
know what they're going to do with that
money if the hatcheries need that much
improvement thank you representative
representative Mills
um representative uh
the new commissioner Scott Mason
actually came to me about this and
wanted to know how to go about it his
his concern is to not not do the Powder
Mill Hatchery it's the fact that this
was a lapse extension and if he didn't
you he thought if he didn't use this
money he was going to lose it which he
would have without getting a lap without
getting the lapse extended and his
intent was to make sure that if he
didn't need all of the money for Powder
Mill that it could he could still retain
it and use it for the other hatcheries
so this what the intent was simply to
amend it mend the title of it so that he
could use any money that he doesn't use
on Powder Mill on the other hatcheries
and I think if necessary we can get him
back here to speak of it
would um as as an interim motion or a an
amendment here uh would the committee
possibly consider adding to the note
that starts on 10 uh something to the
language that it's it's the hope that
they would prioritize uh necessary
improvements to the Powder Mill Fish
Hatchery before expending other funds
representative Newton was something to
that effect uh meet your approval
um
it certainly would go a long ways to
meeting it I'd like to see where exactly
how these funds lapse and because we
just basically gave the state treasure
or authorized to borrow upon the credit
of the state that amount of money if
that hasn't been done yet does it lapse
because they haven't done it isn't it on
the 10-year plan
represent Jack do you want to answer
that question it's it's the monies
haven't been I'll I'll start and you can
correct me if I'm wrong
um so it was fun said hadn't been
expended and if they didn't if they
didn't come up with an immediate need or
what that use was going to be it was
going to go away
so the the understanding I believe I
came in at the end of this conversation
was that they did not want that money to
lapse and and
that's where we are
representative Jack am I interested in
that the status of
whatever we appropriate is considered to
be authorized but unissued bonding and
what the state treasurer does is
depending on the cash flow position of
the state will once a year will issue
General obligation bonds
where the debt service is from the
general fund in this case it would be
Fish and Game
funds but um
we don't issue the debt unless it's
actually needed to cover cash flow
so it's authorized but unissued up until
that point
is that does that answer your question
well yes it does to a degree again you
know if they knew this money was going
to disappear in two years why wasn't I'd
like a good explanation as to why they
didn't do something
and I don't know if anybody here can
answer that well we have we have
projects that for whatever reason don't
get off the ground for a couple years
it's normal procedure to extend an
appropriation until the project that it
was appropriated for is done and then
whatever funds remaining would lapse and
the appropriation would disappear so
this happens you know if you look at
administrative Services you have the
same situation with a lot of the 21
Appropriations where they haven't
started the project because of it takes
a while to to get the RFP out and for a
contractor to for the contract to be
awarded so it's normal practice that the
projects that are bonded that are that
are authorized in hospital 25 may take
you know in some cases eight or ten
years to run all the way to completion
and there's just simply it's normal
practice to extend the appropriation
that's why the section 12 of this year's
represent Newton are you satisfied at
this point in time um at this time yep
would you be in favor of asking to add
an additional note on here absolutely
just after hearing the amount of Arbor
funds they're going to get I just wonder
why this is needed to build up such a
pot of money
what are the plans to use that massive
amount of money I mean they actually
need this
they my
understanding is that our fish
hatcheries are in such a disrepair
number one some of them are
they're looking at whether the practices
at each Hatchery should remain the same
or if the state would be better served
by switching some of those items to
different uh hatcheries
it's a and it's an economic engine
someone's already mentioned for our
state to have these facilities
um
it was deemed to be necessary when the
arpa funds were asked for and approved
so I I'm of the opinion that it is
necessary
Chris is there some sort of language
that we might be able to suggest there I
can do a straw poll and see if the
committee's in favor let's start with
that is the committee in favor of adding
adding a note on here if you do signify
it looks it looks unanimous so so what I
can do is work something out and bring
it back on Friday for the committee to
look at okay and um and if it's
something that's uh meets your approval
then we'd have it added to an amendment
thank you
so the next page is amendment
1005h it was a request from the
Department of military Affairs and
Veterans Services to expand the project
scope from Manchester Readiness Center
any terrorism Force to the Manchester
Readiness Center and conquered
anti-terrorism
no again no change in the value
associated with this
it's just a broadened the scope of the
project
the next one is
um
amendment 10
20 H this is a request from the
Department of Safety
so the department of safety had
requested to expand their Aviation
Hangar project to include construction
and renovation so they had anticipated
they were going to be doing
some construction and then they found
that they're going to be renovating
other parts so they just wanted to
change the again the scope of the
project it is two different projects so
they're both included here that's why
this amendment page is a little bit
longer than the previous
but again I think the department
explained it pretty well to the
committee
no questions
the last amendment in your packet is
zero nine eight zero h
this was a request during the lapse
extension meeting with the Department of
Transportation
so if you see on line 13 The Market
Street Marine Terminal project State
match
so there was a a thought that they the
department would be able to get a grant
a discretionary Grant last biennium
um that specific one didn't happen but
there was a footnote to this um
to this appropriation that would have
allowed them to look for other
discretionary grants when they came
before the lapse extension
um meeting on Monday
they thought they could continue to do
that with this lapse extension it was
pointed out that the note was restricted
to 22 23 so the note online
22 23 convenient just expands it to be
fiscal years biennium 22 23 and 24 25.
the department testified that they think
there will be some discretionary grants
that they could try to access much of
that has to do with the iija
the infrastructure Act
so those are the friendly amendments
that
we've just brought forward to today
so with with the exception of the one we
we spoke of which is 104 H which was the
fish hatchery
um
it doesn't seem that we have any much
discussion on the balance of those
so in this packet that's presented here
if you're in favor of the uh the the
Amendments is shown
um is there any further discussion on
those before I call yes please
it's we're not to that point
so the amendment you're looking at the
amendment right
so that's from the last capital budget
so that was the language it was in the
2021 capital budget so it has nothing to
do with what you're going to decide for
the capital budget for 24.25
the entire section was put in there
because of the note that was the only
thing that was being amended and so it
could easily be seen where the note went
thank you
um if you're in and this is a straw poll
only if you're in favor the Amendments
uh we seem to be in full agreement thank
you
Chris at this time should we uh take up
changes to the project amounts contain
you can do that if you'd like yep all
right
if it would be easier I can point to
so on on the compare document so the
invite go to Environmental Services row
it's the drinking water State revolving
fund State match
the Department of Environmental Services
came in and said that amount is
incorrect under column C it says ten
four eight eight two eight three it's
actually 10
four four eight so there's a forty
thousand dollar pickup for the if you
so I can I can go through all of them
and then you can do a a straw poll or
you can do it each one I don't know how
you want to handle that yeah I'll show
yeah yeah yeah
somewhere along in the process I got
transposed to be an eight instead of a
four
um I don't think there was any specific
blame provided to anybody but it's uh
oh I'm sorry I can go back to page one
I'm sorry
yeah I'm running ahead Department of
Education
on um line 18 is the project to acquire
the 25 Hall Street project you heard
from the governor's budget director
as well in some of the conversation when
the um
commissioner was here that the amount
that was originally proposed for the
project was 7 million not 10.5 million
um so the committee may want to consider
Kathy provincial is the one that came up
with 7 million I've got pretty good
faith in Kathy more than the average
bear and how admin Services just pop
this up 50 percent I don't understand
but I think Kathy would be able to
suggest to the system regardless of what
the appraisal shows that if we approve
I'd give them 7.5 just for the flux in
time
Let's uh let's let's run through and
look at it I'm only four yeah there's
there's just four of these and then
please continue going to page two
line 57 under the Lottery Commission
they had a project included for building
improvements you heard from the Lottery
Commission that
um that money was included in their
operating budget they do not want this
project in the capital budget so the 875
and then the last one
it's the Department of Transportation
they have a seven million dollar in
change request to match the FFA
FAA projects
they came in and testified that that's
overstated by 5.893 million
that they only need a 1.1 million in
change
excuse me yeah um
Mr chair yes
so I will move those four items uh to
reduce uh line 18 to three I'm sorry to
seven million dollars
from ten five
to reduce line 28
to 10 million
four four eight two eight three
to reduce
line
57 to 0 from 875 thousand dollars
and to
and to reduce line 98
to 1 million one hundred and ninety two
thousand one hundred and nine dollars
from seven million eighty five
thousand seven hundred and eight dollars
first drop off
motion motion's been made and seconded
by
by eating thank you
um now
um any further discussion on on the item
yes represent Faulkner we want to
discuss adding the 500 000 that
representative Eaton suggested as a way
to
you know recognize the
forthcoming nature of the administration
I mean the requests collapse advancement
okay let's uh let's be willing to add
we don't want to be punitive here
I'm for representative Eaton I'm just
um
there were several sidebar conversations
out here uh with with public works and
and others and everyone felt comfortable
at the seven million dollar which she
did okay all right
yeah we I'm sorry so
um
there was a discussion with uh Public
Works on whether what the number correct
number was because they started at seven
million dollars and they had done some
calculations on square footage and so
forth in the building and
um but what they neglected to to figure
at the time was if you've been in that
building and we'll go to that building
there's a great big Atrium that rises up
through the center of that building
um which was when when Public Works was
looking at it they were figuring that
square footage into their cost figure
and when it was realized that that
square footage really isn't usable
square footage it brought their number
back in line and they all seemed to
think that seven million would be the
number
I should have shared that with you so
so I unless unless there's further
discussion I think I think we're fine at
the seven minute rep temperatures
briefly Mr chair the um the 7 million
and that estimate was made
they
they got a proposal that estimate was
made uh several months ago or taken into
account any acceleration or any
appreciation of property values
yeah but it's from UNH on on their price
to sell the property they had acquired
the property and found that it wasn't of
continued use for them and then um the
Department of Education then figured
that that was a great space I think they
started out buying that building before
Renovations at somewhere around four
million dollars
so there was work done to the building
and so then it was uh everyone seems to
be in agreement that seven million is
our number which adds uh money back into
our budget
um representative Newman did you have a
question
a comment if that'd be all right sure
yeah
but my understanding also from uh
following up with Mr Shea
there hasn't been a an appraisal done on
that building so I don't know what it
that's my understanding from your
information so I don't know I really
don't know how they could somebody can
come up with an estimate as apparently
they did you know that's fine
um maybe an official appraisal isn't
necessary if everybody's in agreement
with the parties involved
my understanding is the official
appraisal is in the process of happening
they've done an initial assessment of
the building
and that that will follow through but
they were needing some direction uh from
us as to how they were going to move and
if we were to say uh 7 million was our
number they were all moving in that
direction and I'm sure they're going to
have to have appraisals and I I pass
back to you Chris on that
So based on the information I obtained
from both doe and Das Public Works is
there's continuing to be some work work
to look at the value of the building but
the agreement is is a a I think a verbal
agreement between the um usnh
um Kathy prevention and and um
commissioner edelblue to to the usnh is
going to get rid of that building no
matter what they don't need it they
don't want it they don't want to keep
maintaining it
um so they're going to dispose of it so
if doe doesn't take it it will be
disposed of
any further questions
all right so if you're in favor of these
four items as listed and spoke of and
this is straw poll so that we can then
move forward with the bigger discussion
straw poll shows that were unanimous in
that uh
uh thank you uh there seems to be a
little on their repurpose amendments
that we did on on the agency request
sign 27 there's one for liquor that we
don't have an amendment for yet is there
a status on that
uh you know you won't need a um an
amendment for that that's a current
project there it's in this capital
budget so when you get to liquor
you would need to change that title then
I would just have it changed I don't
okay
so let's um let's go turn now to
um
our spreadsheet that we have on the
capital budget
which has the governor's proposal what
we're going to approve by the house and
differences listed and I think our what
we're going to do is just start at the
if you have uh questions on each item as
we get there let's have that discussion
as we go and if there's uh if there's
much disagreement then we may pass and
move on to the next one
so
we can start right up on the top
administrative Services Court facilities
Courthouse generators
uh Governor's proposal is one million
and these were listed as priorities is
the Rochester Courthouse it's 17 million
five hundred thousand
I believe there is to be discussion on
that do you want discussion on that or
represent Kaczynski
yeah well our biggest we had some
question on
the dispersal of the Old Courthouse
okay
supposedly there's a process for doing
that to well you get the maximum for
New Hampshire citizens
and we were told we have a deal made on
that for a trade at substantially lower
value
so uh through through the other
committees that I've had the privilege
of serving uh capital budget and long
range
and in this committee and correct me if
I'm wrong John in this committee we've
been talking about or represent Mills
we've been talking about this Courthouse
first of all the need for it and
the problem
Public Works was having and that we
didn't have enough property
and the discussion then pursued on
the town swapping land and then in turn
receiving the courthouse
and for the number of years
I don't know where the actual cost
breakout is the value of each but it's
been ongoing and going on for several
years and I was okay at this point Chris
would you have anything to add to that
I don't I think you've covered it I mean
if it currently they would need to go
through the long-range committee to
Mr chairman yes please representative if
I could inform the committee as to what
I understand is going on
can I do that
um if it stays in the Realms of
information we can discuss yes
um yeah the
I don't know as representative Kaczynski
said how much the what you do with the
old building how much it matters
with this appropriation and it may not I
do agree with the 17-5 for new
courthouse I think we need it
the problem I have
is the state in the last two years for
six hundred thousand into the existing
courthouse building
and what the city wants to do is they
want to get that courthouse building in
exchange for property that was valued
and from what I believe to be seventy
nine thousand dollars
now the city we were told at a meeting
the other night and I believe I incurred
what I heard
the city has three people or three
businesses that are interested in buying
that building
so the conundrum I've got is a state
representative is should the state get
as much as they can out of that building
which I was led to believe they do when
they sell the building
or do we allow the city
to trade a piece of property that was
they basically got you know 79 000 into
just to sell it to somebody they've got
three people that are interested in
buying the building and that's the
conundrum I've got as a representative
of the city should we do the best deal
and the best interest for the city or as
a state representative should we try to
get the most money back to the state
which I was led to believe what the
state does with buildings when they sell
them they get them appraised and they
try to get what they're worth so this is
a conundrum I'm I've got right now on
how to move forward with this
okay I just want to mention that
the um the value of the land in the swap
is an item that comes through long range
um
long range
committee Capital planning and the value
of of what a building receives when it's
sold is is not a matter of this
committee it's a matter for you as a
state representative I'm sure but this
this number that's in here the 17
million five hundred thousand dollars is
is a separate item
and
there is uh from my time on disposing of
of property goes through a process of
who has the right to request the
purchase of that and sometimes
um those those are done
at a different value for a different
agency as far as the um as far as what
that final cost is if it then ends up
going out to the public is done by
appraisal process but that comes through
that long-range Capital uh committee and
and not through this committee
representative Faulkner and then I'll
come back to you but I think that
answers my question but my understanding
is that if a surplus property is sold
that money comes back into the general
fund it doesn't offset the amount that
has to be bonded all right
follow-up well just that there was a
another item that nobody's that wasn't
mentioned and that's
the uh run around and not going through
the wrong long range planning which you
spoke with me the other day and that
would be if somebody on the committee a
conference adds a line to the budget
and says we're going to trade even for
the land and that could go all around
the long-range planning process
I I don't know the answer to that to be
honest
someone else I just wanted to bring it
any other further discussion on the
Rochester Courthouse yes representative
Jack thank you there was an item in 19
to replace the boilers that project is
complete there's an item 21 for the
design money for this
so that's already been appropriated
representative just a clarification that
the city of Rochester is going to
acquire the courthouse and then
try to sell it or do they have a
specific does the city of Rochester and
maybe this is Curiosity on my pot I want
to repurpose that building for
the cities and the residents uses my my
understanding is that the city will
retain the building
okay thank you no that that Mr chairman
that's all we were told at the meeting
the other night at the city
we're told by the economics development
director that there are three three
parties interested in purchasing the
building from the city
I I heard I heard that okay and that
would that would then be a matter of the
city
in my opinion so okay but we we were
told originally that it was going it was
going to the town and uh or the city so
whatever happens from there
is is the city's decision if
if so done
thank you yep
so should we uh
all right we'll we'll come back to it
Emergency Operations Center replacement
uh mechanical Replacements and repair
which is line number six for seven
questions
uh they're building heating Zone
expansion three hundred and thirty
seeing none Statewide emergency
Statewide emergency fund
I will note that
um we this is the one that we have
no it isn't okay I'm sorry we'll move on
so of the uh of of the items
uh one through
well listed uh two three through nine
um are we
well let's are we in agreement on those
with the we should probably go back to
the the courthouse
okay Rochester Courthouse our straw poll
are you in favor of leaving that in
there at 17 million 500 000 if you are
so we're still unanimous so the rest the
rest of the items there which would be
three through nine
uh which totaled to uh 21 million two
thirty one five hundred uh straw poll
are we in favor of those signify by
raising your hand
we'll move on to line 12 Department of
Corrections replace sewer line and
grinder for four hundred thousand
dollars
the Radio Systems upgrade of nine
hundred and ten thousand dollars
are there questions on either of those
the total there is one million three
hundred ten thousand dollars
yes please represent Newman
yes yes just a question
um
in looking
through the in in this um in the blue
book here
they had requested seven items they got
two
um
are we going to discuss further things
and uh representative Newman brings up a
good point
um we're just looking for agreement at
this point running through these
Department lists and the governors and
there are we are going to end up with
some discretionary money here from laps
and for other projects and we will
discuss those afterwards okay
because there might be and I of course I
believe we're are we waiting for
something from Corrections an update or
on the the kitchen situation or we don't
know anything about that
um I don't believe you were waiting on
the kitchen okay
somebody would have to correct me but I
don't recall that they were coming back
okay
so um so we're at one million three
hundred and ten thousand dollars if
you're a favor of Department Corrections
requests as we see them now signify
Department of Education line 18 acquired
building at 25 Hall Street
the the original request was for ten
thousand five hundred which we have now
10 million 500 000 which we now have
changed to seven million seven million
dollars
which is their only request here so it
would change the line on General funded
portion to seven million dollars any
yes represent blood
so if the Department of Education
doesn't but I say they would continue
leasing the building
that was we heard that at the testimony
I think from last time no they would
move
all right if you're in favor of
inspiring of Education acquiring
building a 25 Paul Street now at seven
let's hold off on that
um
Department of energy fuel assistance
these are other funds aren't they
Federal
uh
I'm sure we can go through that also if
you're in if you're in favor of the
items listed on 22 and 23 which are
federal funded signify by raising your
hand
all in favor represent Below in your
department environmental services which
is line 25.
um we have Dam repairs and
reconstruction at 750
000 it infrastructure at 6 million five
four seven thousand uh drinking water
State revolving fund
um at 10
uh clean water revolving fund State
match
shown as 11 million 361 thousand eight
seventy one
which looks to be a total on the
governor's side of 29 million six
hundred thirty eight thousand twenty
nine dollars
29 598
so corrected would be uh 29 million five
hundred ninety eight thousand zero up to
one zero two nine
any discussion
representative Newman
yes this probably came up along the way
and I I just don't have it in my head
I'm looking at the again in the Blue
Book the
um
the drinking water State revolving match
at 10 488 and then 11 361 they're in
here at different numbers 13.
and 15 respectively yeah so the
department testified to the committee
that they actually had some excess funds
left over that for match okay so that
reduced what they needed to ask for this
all right seeing no further uh
discussion if you're in favor of that
fish and game
um commission line 33 roof replacement
shown on 34 line 34
355 thousand dollars General funded
portion to be
355 thousand dollars
in favor raise your hand
straw poll
we'll move on to Health and Human
Services
Line 39 is federal funding for 5 million
matching funds
um there's electronic visit verification
system line 40 13 million six eight five
thousand
with line 41 is additional monies
provided by the feds which is five
million eight hundred sixty five
thousand
um
General front portion if you drop to 43
line 43 taking out the federal
monies brings us to 19 million three
hundred twenty thousand four hundred
dollars
discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
straw poll on that item for Health and
representative
thank you
unanimous
information technology
Department of Information Technology
line 44
item 45
cyber security program enhancements uh 2
000 dollars
46 line 46 is the financial systems
modernization
third item line 47 is it Services
management system
one million one eight two thousand
general fund portion which would be 49
looks like there's no federal monies
involved here would be for a total of
four million seven hundred fifty six
thousand five hundred dollars
if you're in favor signify by raising
unanimous
we move to line 50 Liquor Commission
line 51 Hampton North and South new
stores
13 million seven hundred and eighty
thousand dollars
headquarters Life Safety improvements
which is line 52 2 million four hundred
thousand dollars
line 53 is a roof replacement for two
hundred and twenty thousand dollars
the uh being a total of 16 million four
hundred thousand dollars
from liquor funds
um dedicated funds not coming from uh
general fund monies are there any
questions on that yes representative
you just answered I believe so that's
the that's the other that's coming
straight from like a
um
okay so they're they're funding this out
of their profit operating uh out of
their profit Enterprise funds is that
the right that's that's correct they're
an Enterprise fund and they'll um in
their operating budget they'll have a
debt service line that would be funded
through their their profits yeah thank
you we we still have it in the budget we
still approve it but it's their funds
represent Kaczynski you with us no yes
thank you shows unanimous
representative McConkey on the liquor
they did request a
um project name change for the
headquarters Life Safety improvements
they ask that it be changed to
um HQ Life Safety improvements
parking lot renovation and roof yes
and the reason for that request is um
as they testified that they're in the
process of redoing the parking lot
um originally they thought they were
just gonna have it repaved but they
found there was some issues underground
that they need to address in order to
repave it
so that appropriation that they have for
the parking lot was also meant for the
roof
they believe they're going to expend the
appropriation they currently have for
the parking lot and may need a little
bit more
they're not sure if they need to do how
much they need to do with the roof if
anything so they had asked that both the
parking and the roof be included in this
title
the renovation is if there's any further
is they do their life safety
Renovations at the headquarters building
because it's an old building they're
concerned they might need to do some
renovation
within this appropriation
and will that be hand is that handled as
a node or this will be changed
if the committee is okay with me making
the change I would make that change in
in the final budget that you see okay
but I would I would ask the committee to
give me an affirmative nod if you want
me to do that reptem Jack I'll move that
we make that change to the title of this
appropriation
moved in second and if you're in favor
raise your hand question Mr chairman yes
please yeah we got it may not matter at
this point but are we going to see all
that in writing what you the changes
that you've made because I I don't hear
so good sometimes and I like to be able
to read exactly what we're doing will we
see that before the final vote yeah
so the document well first you saw the
Amendments and that was partly why I had
the Amendments drafted on the what I
consider the friendly changes so the
members could see what would be the
changes that would go into uh
package the one that some of them are
the one you just approved related to the
headquarters title when I update this
document you'll see the name change in
there is it in here the one that's only
showing the Amendments is it in there no
no that was for the some other changes
but that's just kind of explaining why I
gave you that when I update this
document you'll see the name change to
this project and you'll see references
to those amendments that you've straw
pulled to say that this project has been
uh potentially amended Mr Shaman I just
want to say that when I vote for
something I like to be able to read what
exactly what I'm voting for and I thank
you for being able to get that
information to me before we make a final
vote thank you again
and thank you for that comment and the
intent is that we'll be here Friday when
we start working through this
Friday or Monday
so I don't think we got did we get to
the we did all right Lottery Commission
building improvements
yeah
you've already done that when you zero
thank you all right Lottery Commission
we zeroed out from 875
000 to zero so I think we've already
taken care of that
uh we'll move on to 61 military Affairs
and veteran services
um the uh item 62 is the Nashua
Readiness Center
one one million two hundred and fifty
uh the um
line 63
Nashua Readiness Center minor I see now
your point minor military construction
Federal funding three million seven
hundred and fifty thousand uh the
Plymouth ready line 64. Plymouth
Readiness Center minor military
construction 6 million two hundred and
um line 65 is federally funded at the
Plymouth Readiness Center for 18 million
000.
we have statewide building improvements
line 66 for 500 000 dollars
line 67 Federal
monies of
67 of 1 million five hundred thousand
dollars
we have the line 68 which is
um Nashua hazardous material remediation
for four hundred thousand dollars
so the general funded portion is on line
70 which is eight million four hundred
thousand dollars
Mr chair before you take a vote please
I'll defer to represent belong
just a quick uh question about the
funding is there a funding formula so
it's 75 25 because I'm just I just did a
quick calculation on that is that yes
that's the federal government tells them
that they'll pay 75 or 50 percent or a
hundred percent of certain projects and
then they come and ask for the required
match okay whatever percentage did you
have anything else to add on those I I
did before
um
if you recall when the department came
in on line 68 the Nashua hazardous
material remediation they had requested
if you look at the two-page sheet
on page two line 31 and 32 they had
requested to reduce the four hundred
thousand dollars to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars
and use that hundred and fifty thousand
dollars for land purchase Pembroke so it
was a net zero but they just wanted to
add that
just wanted to remind the committee of
that in case you wanted to consider it
as your cons it doesn't change the total
it just changes the projects
yes representative Kaczynski
um yeah I just when that was presented
to us
it's not I don't know I didn't quite
agree with the fact that they found some
hazardous waste in the land and they
were allowed just to keep it there if
they didn't disturb it that's what he
said the cost would be the 400 000. I I
don't know I don't quite go go for that
myself
I I can't answer why they're able to do
that except it's a military base and
maybe there's certain rules and
procedures that they can follow that
maybe on the outside of the base that
businesses and others wouldn't be
allowed to follow but I can't speak
specifically
um to why the the military Affairs can
um basically cap it and not disturb it
yes I'm going to represent below
thank you just so in Epping we had an
issue with um some hazardous waste
because it's such a little closer to the
microphone I'm sorry because there's so
much uh clay
so you can do clay caps I mean
not that I feel very confident with that
but that is one of the the methods of
dealing with hazardous waste is that if
it is completely covered
within a clay deposit then if you don't
disturb it then it won't go anywhere so
that's I mean that's just my own
speculation on that but that's one of
the things that I've seen in the past
and on a much more General basis for
most of us encapsulating lead paint and
other items as opposed to removing them
you know is another standard practice
where it's so expensive so
um
I don't want to say the word
um I have full faith in in my government
but
it's it seems it seems to be a standard
practice representative
represent yours just briefly in this
case in this location uh
but what it might be uh for anyone's
interest is there are homes within about
100 feet
of that
that location so if I recall from the
presentation yeah they're going to
monitor cap it look at it cap it and
monitor it with with those funds that
were that were being allocated
right representative Jack did you have
something yes yeah I was going to ask if
a motion would be in order to make this
change that's on the
requested chain sheet please all right
to read two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
and then add a new line below it land
purchase Pembroke
or 150 000 dollars
or a net change of no
moved by Jack section by eating
discussion
um if you're in favor of of that change
in the additional line and the the being
a net zero addition to this raise your
hand
passes
um let's go on to the um
because we're down through that so let's
go now to
the total request general fund of eight
million four hundred thousand dollars
for military if you're in favor of that
could signify a straw poll raise your
hand
that passes unanimously straw poll
natural and cultural resources
department line 70.
there is Roofing and repairs 72 for 1.1
million two hundred thousand forests and
land facilities two million eight
hundred Thousand Trails Bureau equipment
one million dollars
Mount Washington Summit infrastructure
an ecology study one million dollars
uh General funded portions six million
dollars
discussion
seeing none if you're in favor of the
line 71 proposal at six million dollars
unanimous
line 79 police standards and training
Council
line 80 they are going to move the Vera
cray tra virtual training virtual
training simulator to reclaim classroom
space
for three hundred thousand dollars
they have converting that classroom once
they get that space cleared a hundred
and fifty thousand uh General funded
portion is four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
discussion
if you're in favor of police standards
and training Council or general funded
portion request of 450 000 raise your
hand
veterans home line 84
line 85 of that proposal is 350 000 for
Statewide
site-wide excuse me drainage and water
life safety improvements 350
000. entry entry Life Safety
improvements two hundred and fifty
thousand
medical lift insulation phase two 165
000.
for a total for the veterans home on
line 89 of General funded portion at
765 thousand dollars
discussion
if you're in favor of that straw poll
moving on to line 90 Department of
Safety
um New Hampshire State Police message
switch replacement one million ninety
three thousand five hundred dollars
line 92 is the helicopter improvements
for the State Police 525
000.
general fund listed on 94 is for one
million six hundred eighteen thousand
and five hundred dollars
yes please represent Kaczynski yeah and
a helicopter
um
I remember him coming forward for 1.5
million and I'm looking in the book here
it says general funds 525 Highway fund
615 other funds 360 360
000 what are the other funds anyway
the other funds are Turnpike funds
those are not going to be bonded as part
of cap the capital budget there's
statute that restricts how Turnpike
funds can be bonded so if you look in
the actual capital budget as introduced
on page four there's a note that says
the appropriation and sub paragraph two
which is related to the highway fund
portion
she'll be for the total project amount
of 1.5 million to include General funds
in Section 1 and any Turnpike funds
thank you thank you any further
discussion
if you're in favor of Department of
safety's request is as spoken uh General
funded portion being one million six
hundred eighteen thousand five hundred
we move on to line 95 Department of
Transportation
Aeronautics line 96 Aeronautics Rail and
Transit
excuse me
um line 97 which is federal match for
the FAA projects federal funds 63
million seven hundred seventy one
thousand three seventy three
Federal match
for FAA projects
seven mil which is
we reduce that to 5 million
please we reduced that to 1 million
109 dollars
I stand corrected
the uh matching funds line 99
for transit buses and passenger
amenities uh five hundred and seventy
thousand
so our new total for the general funded
portion which is 101 do you have a
number for that I don't
right
foreign
General funded
right so everyone understand and your
federal fund will change from the 63
million will change to six nine six six
four nine seven two
six nine six six four
nine seven two
okay could you repeat that one more time
please yep so the federal portion will
be six nine
six six four six
yes representative for the record how is
it that we get 70 million dollars in
federal funds with only matching it with
1.2
million is that that's
seems to be out of the range of most of
the funding ratios some of those are
representative Jack did you want yeah
the funding formula for airport
Improvement project if a funding is 90
Federal
five percent local match and five
percent State match
so what we're appropriating here is the
in addition the infrastructure Act
has re lowered the match requirement for
some of the funds that are coming in so
if you have the Department's uh booked
with this cover on it
if you look at
um page two
it's in the small print that talks about
the project justification but it it
explains there why the match has
decreased from the normal five percent
it's a shame it's not more of those
isn't it all right so every everyone's
aware of what the new number is
uh clerk do you have the number for
General funds
one million seven hundred sixty two
thousand one hundred and nine dollars
any further question on that
representative Kaczynski well I just
wrote down one one million 192. I hear
that wrong before it's one six we'll
double check our number no there um if
you if I might that was the the new
number for when you reduced on line 98
the number that was just mentioned was
the total of 98 and 99 so it's the one
one nine two 109 plus the 570.
570 000. all right if you're in favor of
Department of Transportation aeronautic
Rail and transits raise your hand
unanimous
all right so now we're down to totals
uh you're down to on on 109 110 is the
highway fund request I apologize uh so
Department of Safety under Highway 109
New Hampshire State Police
message centered
um
256 000 line 109
line 110 is New Hampshire State Police
Helicopter Improvement
615 thousand dollars
from the highway funded portion 87 871
000 dollars
bonds others
Highway
871 thousand dollars
am I correct on that
all right any question
if you're in favor of that department of
safety requests signify by raising your
total Appropriations one and two
we can pass on that can't we can go on
yeah okay
thank you so we will move on to uh line
um
UNH biological Services it lists the
hide Center Keene State Elliott Student
Center
um
and if we go to with that would be 17
million dollars
and if General funds portion is 17
million dollars and this 17 million
dollars is carrying over from
the final of
the keep project so back in 2019 uh this
committee agreed with the university to
appropriate a total of 42 million
dollars over three bienniums
first year was 10 million or the first
biennium was 10 million second biennium
which we're currently in is 15 million
and the balance would be in 24 and 25
which is 17 million and it's for
projects that as you see in the line
there at UNH Plymouth State and Keene
and I believe when the university system
came in they provided a pretty detailed
document showing you their calendar and
the match that they have to the state
funds to complete these projects
this is here to show the committee that
the this appropriation has already been
made
but it does affect your 24-25 capital
budget appropriation and that's what you
see on line 37 137 excuse me so you see
that this total capital budget contains
Appropriations for the general fund of
129 million
so with that explanation the university
system showing is a 17 million dollar uh
obligation of your favor of that
signified by raising your hand
unanimous
all right so the find the final numbers
we won't go on the final numbers there's
adjustments that need to be made
and so forth uh we'll wait for the
documentation we're talking about to
come back on Friday and then we can
discuss that further
um
we still have
um time here
um
I'd like to take a 10 minute break and
then come back and uh
discuss other the additional agency
requests at that time
our goal is to be out of here no later
than four o'clock I don't know that
we'll even be here that long
we'll get going in just a moment here
all right we will go in and I as I
promise we're not going to be here past
four o'clock so we'll go as far as we
can uh let Chris make some adjustments
so give us time to think about it and
then we'll talk again on Friday
so when we when we take in the savings
that were found earlier
between the um the
um Hall Street uh drinking water program
Lottery Commission Department of
Transportation
we have found 10 million three hundred
eight thousand five ninety nine
if you add in the repurpose funds from
the lapse that gives us and there's it's
a little might change just slightly but
that's another three million eight
hundred thirty thousand sixty three
dollars
so we're sitting right now with the
possibility of 14 million dollars
fourteen hundred and thirty nine
thousand two hundred and twenty nine
dollars
we're we're going to uh we're going to
uh and we're going to go through the
additional agency requests and talk
about where monies might be appropriate
appropriately placed
I want you to bear in mind that this is
really this is really highly unusual in
my 20-year
that I've been in and out of here in
that if you remember what um our former
chairman spoke about earlier
um all the arpa funds that were brought
into this process
made it so much easier that we weren't
fighting over so many more projects we
know that there was a billion dollars
worth of requests came down and you know
we're in the neighborhood of 120
000 120.
um that we're we're going to appropriate
out of here so
I'd like to speak of some items that I
we've said it several times it has
always been our desire and we have
worked extremely hard over my terms here
to fund to CTE projects
um one we were fortunate is coming
through
the governor's budget not coming my not
coming through us
but they neglected to fund the
winnisquam regional CTE Center
renovation
the and the governor said that he left
it out of his request or didn't consider
it because the the it was an unknown
item of whether the town or the regional
school was going to come up with their
their appropriation of that so he left
it off
I've had conversations uh with the um
with the director of that school
and at last time it missed by a mere
I think it was listed somewhere it
missed by less than 11 votes to
appropriate that money
it is still a high priority for them
they have held I think he told me three
public sessions up till now uh talking
to the people how important it is on
their programs that they want to expand
they're feeling much better about it
they're actually doing another public
forum
in two days and I believe the final vote
of the school district happens on the
27th of this month
I think it's important to keep this
project in our in our capital budget
in the in the event that on the 27th
let's say it didn't come true and that
they weren't able to get their money
I'm suggesting that Friday we develop a
list of projects to Total seven million
649 thousand dollars
that in the event that this does not get
approved that we pass it out of this
house that this is where we want those
Monies to go to
we've done that in the past we did last
time because there was all the
uncertainty of the arpa funds we
developed a list that Chris will
developed for us and we passed that
through the house and said to the Senate
that these are our priorities if those
monies come available so we've done this
sort of thing before
we could we could adopt the other
position where we don't put this in our
program in our budget and we put it on
the side but it doesn't show anywhere
near the strength of uh how important
this is to us so I'm I'm hoping that
you'll consider you'll consider keeping
that project in there because if we only
if we only start approving one CT
project School a term uh it'll be over
20 years before we get back to that
school
and Technology changes buildings need to
be upgraded and hopefully we're adapting
to what's necessary in our Workforce so
um so I'm going to propose that we move
the winnisquam regional CTE Center
renovation into this budget as part of
that other monies that we spoke of
we'll do a straw
uh any discussion on that before we do a
straw
it's a quick question yes
and that would be for 7 million
approximately seven six yep seven six
four nine six six three
it's shown on um it's on the additional
agency requests it's uh line ten
got it thank you
and this is deducted from the 14 million
yes okay
thank you
if if you're uh in favor of that if
there's no further discussion if you're
in favor of that signify by raising your
hand
next next area that we have been
extremely supportive of
is the community college system
and the governor
um
was not funding
line
and they have a request there for
3.3 million four hundred twenty five
thousand dollars and some change
and they also had as one of their
priorities which was line
14 14.
which was the respiratory therapy
program teaching equipment and teaching
space renovation
again our committee has always been
extremely supportive of of adding
programs that are necessary and that we
know the workforce New Hampshire
Workforce is out there waiting for
had a discussion with um with the
community college system and I floated
that
you know where where is your need is is
the critical need over the what I
perceived my need which was the
expanding the program
and if you if we were to find a one and
a half million dollars
to assist you where would you where
would you spend that money
and their day after a lot of thought
they came back critical maintenance
would be of Greater service to them
so
um I'm suggesting
um and they'll be Surplus after this
also but I'm suggesting that we consider
1.5 million dollars for critical
maintenance of the community college
system
discussion
yes please Mike represent beggar uh
thank you Mr chair
um
when I look at the needs
the 1.5 to me is more important and one
of the reasons I'll say it is they have
Appropriations in now from past you know
they're elapsing for critical
maintenance and it's not done
I if I was going to have to choose
between the two I would go for the
respiratory therapy because it's such a
shortage of that and again it's
Community College where people get
trained and pretty much stay in the
state thank you okay
I think it's you and me on that uh go
my apologies so just so in this category
of community ecology system so are you
proposing
a 1.5 million dollars to has to be
allocated for to cover these three
subjects
no I'm I'm I'm suggesting after speaking
to the um
to the Community College I'm suggesting
that we permit we allow additional 1.5
million dollars for critical maintenance
only
so changing so that line which is 3.425
would go to 1.5 that line uh 12
correct
got it okay thank you
representative
I just would concur with Mike that um
the 1.5 in
uh
the respiratory therapy gives a
continual return on investment uh and
puts people out in the field right now
and there is a huge shortage by not
doing it it also leaves us at a
disadvantage with the state of
Massachusetts where they can skip across
the border and do the program and they
do
Surplus or lapse critical maintenance
money now whether it's because the
product project they're working on came
in under or they just didn't feel like
going through the Hoops to go through
fiscal to use some of the excess money
elsewhere I don't know but I would be
more inclined to go the respiratory
therapy okay thank you representative
represent Faulkner
I I agree with that you need to fund the
respiratory
a therapy program but it's
what reason can we do both we give them
the 1.5 million they need or think they
need for critical maintenance as well as
this program I would say I would be in
favor of doing both because it
this is absolutely the agency that has
the biggest bang for the buck of all the
things that we that we helped fund I
think is so important to the state and
I'm be happy to help them however we
need to
thank you further comment question yes
I'm sorry representative Faulkner raises
an interesting question so how much
money did get lapsed from the community
and I think we need I think
representative Jack grenita
just for clarification the community
college is asking to have Labs
extensions on
um one of their critical maintenance and
um well two that one that's in the
budget and they're asking for a second
one that was not contained
um just to be clear
yep yep
so that would that would help them do
critical maintenance if they got those
yes
they would finish up so when I talked to
Community College about lapse extension
stuff
um they've spent most of the money in
all their critical maintenance they just
wanted to make sure that the project
didn't close before they finished paying
all the bills
so they've encumbered the bill they may
not have closed it out yet all right
thank you thank you for that
clarification represent Mills
thank you Mr chair just want the
committee to know that originally
chairman McConkey
I think we've all just about said the
same thing we'd like to support the
respiratory therapy program and he kind
of nudged nudged them and let them know
that we would be very very
amenable to to giving them a million
five for the respiratory committee they
came back to us and said thank you very
much but we would rather take that money
if you do have it available and use it
for critical maintenance so this was
actually their choice to do it this way
we can of course overrule them and say
Here's the million five it's it's got to
be used for respiratory
therapy but their request was actually
to take that money and put it towards
critical maintenance
further discussion yes representative
thank you chairman this two quick points
did I recall when the president of the
community college system was had during
testimony that
did they not have a a budget together or
a plan together for Capital Improvements
because they were working on it if I
recall if they do oh
okay I
recall a testimony saying he and they
didn't
the governor's office didn't fund
correct okay all right so these are
their requests um so presently there is
a
the Therapy Program is up and running
they just want to improve it and extend
it or and uh and and propagate it if you
will
um
no I I believe this is a new program
this is a brand new program that's
trying to initiate okay I just
I'm looking at teaching space renovation
okay so this is a brand new program
um
and it sounds like they have additional
critical maintenance needs that they're
they've had on the back burner that's
what they they have a large need for
critical maintenance okay the governor
didn't fund it thank you
yes representative Jack uh thank you it
seems like there's a strong sense in the
committee that they would like to fund
the respiratory therapy it looks to me
with what we have remaining that we
could consider that we might be able to
uh squeeze some money into critical
maintenance and fund
whatever else we want to fund and still
fit within what we have available so we
might be able to do both
uh at us at a lower level
thank you representative below
just to try to build on on what was just
said so if looking we had 14 million
just I'm just running it looks like we
have still about six and a half million
dollars that we haven't talked about
because taking care of that CTE setting
that aside
looking at it starting with the 14
million that was was left over taking
that out we're at about six and a half
million that we haven't done anything
about we're talking about this and
talking about the the two I mean I hate
to leave maintenance is just isn't sexy
right I mean it isn't but if you don't
do it man think about those pictures of
the prison what happens when you don't
take care of Maintenance it really is
bad
you also I think you were talking about
just maybe lower system
lower the amounts uh on both those lines
and at least try to address those two
areas both maintenance and
um the respiratory program
so that is an option we have I'm I'm I
would like to suggest
that we at least look at a
look at putting in the one and a half
million dollars
as as a figure to start the conversation
let's go through let's go through more
of this and if we can bring more money
back here and we decide that's what we
want to do and I like that idea then
we'll come back with more funds as we
find them but I'd like to suggest that
we we target 1.5 million dollars at this
point and then we can thrash out if we
can have more money or not
and if we if we don't then what it is
we're going to say that we would like
them to move forward with representative
yeah I agree Mr chairman uh I think I've
been listening to debate I am torn I
think we should go through everything
and then maybe come back later to the
item and maybe decide maybe to add more
money and maybe do both I I see both
points but I eventually I think we've
got to make a decision but we have I
think a little bit of room to play with
as far as the available funds thank you
okay represent milts and then I'll come
back to you representative Newton I just
thought I just wanted to make a motion
for a straw poll to at least put forth
the figure of 1.5 million dollars for
Community College at this point and if
we're agreed on that then we can because
we've got a list of other things we want
to go through that gives us a dollar
figure
to work with no matter where we put it
now we can always come back and add to
it but at least start at 1.5 million
thank you well I want to acknowledge
I'll come back to you representative
Newton has hand up to yes thank you Mr
chairman I'd like to see the totals of
the agency request
and we see what we've got for requests
for money and how much we've got to
spend
and I'd like to see us at some point
look at trying to separate the wants
from the needs
and I think you've made a pretty good
argument with your winner Squam and your
critical critical maintenance as pretty
much being what we're looking at as
needs
but I'd like to see the total amount
that we're looking at and what we've got
to actually
spend and that might get us in a little
more of a reality of where we're going
with this because right now it looks
like it's a lot more than the 14 million
that we've got to spend that has been
requested it certainly is
um and we are going to get there my hope
is to go go through the items we have
here see where that number is
um and um and then we will work to
either move up uh move items down or uh
maybe we request more money so thank you
we're going to get you there
um represent yours
disregard thank you thank you
okay thank you
um we will go to
yeah straw polls straw poll at least 1.5
million dollars appropriated
we seem to be unanimous thank you for
that
um line for Department of Human Health
and Human Services
22 on the agency request glencliffe
wastewater treatment improvements
we this facility
um
is not close here to Concord
um they do wonderful wonderful work
there
um this wastewater treatment
improvements
has been a critical need for them for
years and it continues to be ignored
you talk wish and you know what we need
they the agency
has repurposed some monies in part of
this proposal Chris
so the agency in an effort to try to
fund
this project tried to lapse um
projects they didn't get to the 1.4
million but they did get a couple
hundred thousand dollars of General
funds that's in that 3.8 million dollars
of repurposed funds that you are
discussing thank you
so I I see this as as a need and I'm
suggesting that we put one point one
million four hundred and thirty two
thousand dollars to this is their
discussion yes representative Abbott
yes I think when we say it's a need I
mean the alternative
um to not doing this is closing the
place down
and I think what you know where it's
located in rumney and it serves the
folks in the North country and I don't
know what the alternative would be to
this facility and that's why I agree
with you Mr chairman
um that
um
thank you representative well said
representative alone please right and
just to add that so it could be
Pennywise pound foolish if we don't do
representative Mills thank you Mr chair
once again even though it's it sounds
like a large amount 1.4 million
their understanding was they gave up
they lapsed a lot of money back towards
us I think it was in excess of
seven eight hundred thousand dollars
that they gave up in lapses that we've
got in our 3.8 million aforementioned
lapse money so we'd actually only be
giving out of this four 1.4 million
they've already contributed 800 000 of
it
does that make any sense
any further discussion
straw poll Glenn Cliff wastewater
treatment improvements 1.43 million
dollars
um
representative Newton did you vote
okay so um whatever our count is minus
one
another department that we have always
tried to find more money when we can
the state park system under the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
people not only come to our state for
our state park system
our own residents find this a Haven of
where to go and if you live in a less
fortunate place to be able to come to
this beauty is just beyond reach for
most people so we have always been able
to find in my starting my ninth term we
have always looked to find money here
and they were fortunate to get some arpa
funds uh if you remember when the
commissioner was here
um there were a project brought forward
the Connecticut Lakes Headwaters Road
repairs and she had a second item which
was Paving of the State Park parking
items 35 and 36.
the Connecticut River Headwaters had
asked for Road repairs that asked for a
million 2.5
one one and a half million dollars and
the commissioner had asked 250 000 for
parking lots
parking lots are a liability parking
lots uh we have to we have we we need to
take care of those because it's like our
highways if we don't do something to our
Highway within nine years we lose it we
start again a parking lot I'm sure has
as quick or quicker uh depreciation I'm
suggesting that we put 250
000 into the parking lots as they had
requested
and I'm asking instead of 1.5 million
that we put five hundred thousand
dollars into the Connecticut Lakes
Headwater
Road repairs
it's it's a million plus was how many
acres was it it's a huge it's a huge
property
thank you
yeah
and uh the the the
appropriation of that had started in
public works that uh uh representative
Chandler speaker Chandler had um
had made mention and when they had done
that they had set up some funds inside
of that that they were hoping to take
care of these needs but they've they've
fallen way short I would like to provide
more money but I I think us giving a
half a million dollars to this
certainly will let them prioritize what
needed what needs to be done now and
they can come back in Future
Appropriations so I'm asking that we
increase the appropriation to the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources
by 750
000 dollars
discussion
yes represent me
Mr chair I agree with you 100 on doing
the money and I just want to add in I
think you were here at the same time
that I was when we leveraged this
property and part of the agreement was
that we would maintain those roads so
this is keeping the word faith and trust
of the State of New Hampshire in doing
so
thank you representative
representative to the the State Park
parking lots uh over at Pawtuckaway
there's there could be some some help
needed there and certainly the access
road leading up to the beach parking lot
of Pawtuckaway State Park to use you
know some washing out there's some
potholes uh I I can understand the need
to the entire park uh Park system
parking lots for sure thank you thank
you
further discussion representative Jack
yeah on the plus side over the last few
bienniums since I've been here we've
tried to give them everything they
wanted plus a little and we've over
thought over that time we've we've
really knocked down the amount of things
that they have to do if this is the only
thing that they're asking for it means
that everything else we've gotten in
pretty good shape so I'm strongly
supporting
let's change thank you
yes representative yeah what other
funding sources do they have and what's
can you answer that so they have the
park fund they have the trail funds
um they have some arpa funding that was
uh provided to them
um so they're essentially a self-funded
agency
but I don't have the total number of
what their operating budget is off the
top of my head I'd have to get that for
if you're uh straw poll if you're in
favor of 750 000 between these two
projects
we have
those opposed
okay all but one thank you
next item I'd like to go to
um we had a house bill
house bill 199.
which was uh Department of
Transportation which was
um
Sioux projects Carol and Stratford
Freight rail improvements and koas
County Freight rail improvements the
request was for a million dollars
we have over
at least two bienniums before this uh
this being the third have made this
appropriation uh and it's it's it's
dependent on them getting matching funds
um for their rail projects and this is
this is for rail this is for Freight for
Rail and the ties and the bed underneath
the money's also been used for culverts
and bridges and so forth
I've had further conversations on this
project and the Carol and Stratford
Freight rail improvements
can be downgraded from a half a million
dollars to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars
before I discuss further I would I would
like to
say that 250 000 would be added for the
Carolyn Stratford Freight rail
improvements and 500 000 for the koas
county Freight rail improvements
that
um
in my opinion if you think of what's
moments here in our country and rail
derailments and so forth
I think it's extremely important to keep
up with the rails they talked about from
going from segmented
sections of rail to continuous weld the
number of ties that can be replaced we
had in in our budget earlier talking
about so many million dollars for those
improvements but that doesn't get them
close to where they are so we have we
have always been supportive of this and
I would like to suggest that we expend
um
once again for this project
represent below
I'm sorry I'm just trying to do the math
so they're on lines 45 46 and 47 that
adds up to about
what about a million six so which is is
that what you're referencing through
those three lines or is this in addition
to or I'm just trying to figure that out
I'm sorry it's
let me find out where it is
it's House Bill 199 that the committee
retained oh okay so this isn't this I'm
sorry I'm just referencing this Edition
I'm sorry so we yeah we we had the
hearing for House Bill 199 and then we
retained it
okay and we didn't pass funds for it
because we typically bring it in at this
point into the capital budget
representative Jack the lines 45 46 47
are a Department of Transportation
request that wasn't funded in the
governor's budget that we typically do
fund some money
for these for these repairs uh the two
the the item the amount we're talking
about now is not on this sheet okay
so there's no overlap on this it's just
this is in addition to
got it and dependent that they get the
that they get the matching funds and
they report back through
long range
Capital Improvement
capital budget overview capital budget
overview
um overseas the funds as they come in
make sure that they not only receive the
matching funds but what it is they're
going to you know what they propose to
do next so it has oversight from the
time it's approved by the legislature
and it goes out
if you'd like Mr chair I can read The
Narrative that would be added to this
please
um so in the last capital budget for the
same type of project The Narrative was
the sum appropriated in subparagraphs
shall be matched to private funds of an
equal amount for each project the
Department of Transportation shall
report on the use of the appropriation
and matching private funds for each
project to the capital budget overview
Committee in October and April for each
year of the biennium so that's the
oversight that the chairman was
referencing
thank you
represent include here okay thank you Mr
chairman uh as a co-sponsor of House
Bill 199 I'm in full agreement with what
you're proposing here I just feel too uh
sorry that one argument is to try to
reduce the number of heavy trucks that
use our road hauling this stuff and I
think the more we invest in Freight rail
uh the what we we do hopefully is reduce
the wear and tear on our roads and I
mean the heavy trucks they put wear and
tear on our roads and we've had
discussions just to talk about
funding the highway fund I don't want to
get into funding the highway fund today
but I think this is one small way to
reduce uh the wear and tear on our roads
especially I think in kowas County
Carroll and Stratford but it's also a
Statewide issue so I would ask this
committee to put this item in thank you
yes representative Kaczynski
I totally oppose spending one dollar
for these private railroads
they're private companies
we're not we're not uh privy to getting
any of their profits at the end of the
year you know these people bought these
railroads with the intent of using them
from for themselves now this Stratford
County Railroad when I looked into this
the owner of this is Boston sand and
gravel down in in Boston
so they own RCP Aggregates and the
primary purpose is to transport sand
from Ossipee New Hampshire to Boston for
cement
it's a private transportation line in
testimony we heard that they're saving
loads of money from Trucking the sand
the only other customer to have is
Eastern Propane gets some propane on the
way back now they received the grant a
huge Federal grant of over four million
dollars in 2014 and part of that they
were supposed to be looking for more to
increase the customer base
so there's no more customers here
so I don't know what are we trying to
save a railroad line for what if there's
world war three and we need to truck
um I don't know what out of Ossipee or
the North Country I really I don't know
I mean
this is a wealthy private business here
the last I looked at the last budget
they were over well over 100 million
dollars in revenue and I think it's
personally disgusting to hit up the
taxpayers in New Hampshire to be paying
for private businesses here I brought
this up to several constituents
and anybody there was not one person
that agreed in fact they were they
couldn't believe it that we were
expending money to a private company
and
I don't know what I could say you know
years years ago people called them the
robber barons the carnegies the the
Rockefellers and yet I don't know what
do you call a multi-millionaire that's
that's looking to sap money from from
New Hampshire citizens I mean maybe
we've been doing it I I I just can't see
why this is done
okay you know for somebody who believes
in small government and small spending
representing constituents here with
their hard-earned money and giving it to
a private company even at CSX they're no
they're no little player in the game
here
you know you got this line goes from
Quebec to Vermont and New Hampshire and
Maine these people aren't going to stop
transporting things if we don't give
them this this money here
that outfit the Boston sand and gravel
you know I challenge them well okay
they're gonna we're gonna shut it down
maybe get some permits for for sand in
Massachusetts to open up some new pits
down here and transport into Boston I'm
sure this is a lot more
profitable forum
to do this thank you thank you
representative uh just like to point out
that the um
that the state of New Hampshire owns the
owns the land
unless of course passenger rail were to
come back the the rail right-of-way here
this money is for the Improvement of the
ties and rails and you and I are never
going to agree on this point and I
certainly understand your passion and I
certainly respect that but
the representative cloutier's point of
the number and I believe it's in the
hundreds of thousands of trucks that are
saved from driving up and down here and
I would profess that we're not saving
them money we're saving wear and tear on
our roads and passengers in the amount
of traffic that's generated by that do
we have further discussion
a quick rebuttal
on that that truck traffic
if you figured a five day week that
comes to about 560 trucks a day and if
you sat at the Hampton tolls I think
you'd find it's a drop in the bucket
thank you sir uh represent Faulkner the
idea that we are
have public infrastructure that benefits
private companies uh it happens all over
the place we put
money into airports that that have pet
Airlines and private plane owners we put
money into the highways that benefit
truckers and vehicle owners I think that
uh the model is such that we need to
evaluate the public benefit but that the
idea that
we have private users is is just common
because that's that's what we do thank
you sir
uh further further
yeah could you clarify uh you said that
the state owns all the right-of-ways of
the railroads or is that this this right
of way we do
the road bed well how then
only when this railroad stops ceases the
goal then it goes back to the homeowners
or the landowners if if it was
determined that um
passenger rail were to come back to the
state
um it would be one of the rights of
reversion reverting back to their
ownership
represent Parker we have a state law
since uh
late 60s I think that any
any version the railroads if they own it
they what they own is a set of Rights
basically you know virtually all the
rights in the land but if they cease to
operate a railroad or don't pass it on
to somebody who's operating a railroad
it now comes back to the state rather
than to the um to the Buddy landowners
by a statue we passed several decades
ago and we did pay a fee to the railroad
for the rights of that of that
right-of-way
but there are restrictions of when it
could revert back if uh for you know
so that we would have to give it back
further question representative just
briefly um along with the right-of-way
and the proposed Rail and uh tie
Replacements we own the culverts as well
correct and if the cover is not
maintained there could be issues
further about with drainage beyond
beyond the railroad beyond the railroad
right away you were correct on that
representative Edgar
uh thanks Mr chair if I could have it um
by line item uh right now
well there is it is here no no no
requests
okay
okay the the request is to bring in
um 750
000 dollars
uh for the Carol Carol and Stratford
Freight Line in the kowas county Freight
rail improvements 500 000 going for the
koas county Freight the remainder 250
000 for the Carolyn Stratford Freight
rail improvements if you are in favor of
if you were opposed
all but two thank you
last item I have to discuss is under
um it's an item for three hundred and
thousand dollars
line two was it
two chillers for pro 29 Hazen Drive
let's be like Mark writing this with a
misspelling here so
I believe I believe this was one of
their highest priorities
it was and I believe that these chillers
are at Hazen Drive the DS building if I
I'm I'm not the person to ask that
um
it looks like a massive cone up there I
can tell you I'm in the building all the
time
so this was one of their highest
priorities uh we have an off we have
several departments are in that building
and I think this was uh a well needed
item at three hundred thousand dollars
I'd like to add that I believe these are
the items I had listed here
and if you move on this item at least
for consideration at this time we still
7566 remaining by my or some number
you'd have about 1.7 million
that would be the number still
one one million seven hundred fifty
seven thousand five hundred and sixty
six dollars yeah
spelling and math were not my uh
uh discussion
yes representative Abbott
yes I think that um
I don't know how far we could go with
that but with the
um money we have left and is
which former chairman Graham brought up
there's some attention that have to be
given to planning for the new Men's
prison
my my understanding
on the the governor's request was
50 million dollars to be set aside
the finance has in my understanding
has reduced that request to 10 million
dollars at this time
the 10 million dollars is the number
that they believe
will will give them the engineering the
planning for what they want to do
so
in my understanding is that it was to
set aside 40 million dollars as sort of
like Capital Improvement
and they would hoping that they would do
that first for one or two years or
whatever and then have to bond the
balance
Finance I understand when the revised
um
when the revised numbers came in saw
that they there could be as much as uh
30 to a 60 million dollar shortfall in
the revenue projections when they did
the latest round and I'm speaking out of
term this is what I understand
that they figured at this point in time
that they would remove 40 million from
that and put the 10 million dollars in
which would be what we've done similarly
many times here saying you have a
project that you can't build right away
so we set aside the money for uh for the
planning purpose that's my understanding
so
um we are we also if if we move forward
with this we still have that balance and
we still have the seven million dollars
plus that the CTE
um money for win a Squam in the event
that that doesn't move forward uh that
we could give some guidance for
repurpose but I unfortunately we just
don't have that sort of money in our
budget
oh yes so so before we so the two
chillers at Hazen drive at
um three hundred thousand dollars
so yes represent Jack thank you if in
fact we have somewhere in the area of
1.7 million left that would do nicely to
which is
which is the dot requested uh railroad
line items that
are are in my mind pretty important to
keep those in good repair I'm sorry I'm
not on the right line with you yet on
the agency request 45 46 and 47 under
dot it's the railroad repairs that
1.6
plus or minus yeah
does everyone understand the
representatives request
represent Mills Mr chair I just want to
bring up as much as I love doing that
kind of repair and I certainly agree uh
I'd want to remind everybody that week
put 1.5 million into the Community
College
thinking that we could come back and
talk a little bit about that too we
still haven't decided what we were going
to recommend that 1.5 if we move forward
with this
we've just about taken care of the money
that we've got right now just thought
I'd bring it up thank you
representative
yes Under The Heading of just thinking
I'll bring this up too does anybody else
remember that when D.O.T was in here I
think
when they were
when they were speaking I bet he
mentioned five or six or seven times
about five items that they really wanted
and that just didn't make the governor's
list doesn't I mean there were several
things
um
Department of Transportation there well
there were listings on here of the
projects that they wanted yeah
um but unfortunately to fund those items
it comes out of the highway fund
and if when we've had serious as there's
there's a need and a want but if we
those funds would come out of that and
we would have less money to pave and
build Bridges
and so we we've we've steered clear of
that in the past all right thank you
thank you for that I'm hoping our
president can come up with that money
yeah and all in all honesty Federal
appropriation yes representative yes so
where are these lines located in these
Bridges
or the suggestion that representative
Jack I thought that's what you're
talking about
I I don't know the answer to that
I I suggest we're getting a little long
on on a long day
um and I have a commitment in my town at
six o'clock I mean we just went through
a bunch of money here
yeah so um why don't I'm gonna I'm gonna
suggest that I think there's Merit in
that request I think there's Merit in
more money for the Community College
um and we would I suggest we come back
on Friday and try and thrash through the
remainder of that and what we should
would like to prioritize the money for
the CT project in the event
um that project doesn't move forward
I'm open for discussion for the next few
minutes yes representative Newman could
I just get clarification when a Squam
was going to vote on did you say Friday
the 27th 27th of this month
is our intent that we're going to pass
this out of here out of committee ahead
okay
I think we've done tremendous amount of
work again
yeah
so um yeah
so Friday Friday it looks like we could
be in a point that um we'll work on the
balance of that
um we're still scheduled for Monday so
we'll put we'll we're gonna have to have
time to write amendments and so forth
but
correct it's going to take a little bit
of time to to make the amendment
together pull the amendment together so
depending how quickly decisions are made
I'll give you a better sense on Friday
when I think we can have an amendment to
I think your exec on Mondays scheduled
for 11 and you're you have a work
session at 10 o'clock in case you had
yeah
Friday at 10 o'clock
yeah and Mondays at 10 another work
session and then at 11 is a exact
do you have a plan when you would do the
um
no I hadn't really done a full thought
on that
what I was
possibly going to try to do is start the
amendment with OLS
because you've done so much today to see
if I can get a draft Amendment for you
on Friday
that you then it'll be less work to
change that if you have to add or delete
something or change something it would
be less to do that
represent Mills
would it help if we if that 1.5 million
that we've so far committed to the
community colleges would it help if we
had a fast straw poll here and decided
whether we wanted it that to go to
critical maintenance or
um
the respiratory for the purposes of
doing the amendment it would yes okay I
okay we're dragging you back for one
more
so the discussion is
um on the 1.5 million dollars
for the benefit of getting the amendment
drafted
a straw poll
by the committee of whether you would
like to have that money purposed for the
respiratory program or whether you would
rather have it done for
critical maintenance at this point in
time
keeping in mind we still have time to
revisit this
so let's start with if you're in favor
of the 1.5 million being purposed for
the respiratory program
signified by raising your hand strop
hole
six members
and if you're in favor of instead of
repurposing that for or excuse expending
that 1.5 for critical maintenance raise
six seven eight as I count it yeah
you were Which Way represent below I'm
just so the next thing we just say
I mean if we try to split the money it
doesn't make it it doesn't help either
way right I mean basically that's
undermine so it's either going to be 1.5
or for one or the other yeah got it okay
so it would appear the committee
recommendation and for those that are
interested in critical needs we have we
have availability to go back there and
add money back for that infrastructure
all right
with that Chris anything else we can do
to help
no I I think I have enough to to get
started with um I'll update the compare
sheet to go with your straw polls today
so you'll have a an easy cheat sheet and
then and I'll try to get the amendment
started and hopefully have a draft
Amendment
um of the entire Bill possibly on Friday
represent Mills yeah I just want this uh
to thank Mr Shea and be happiness
committee because without these cheat
sheets you have no idea of how long a
process this is and trying to balance
between seven or eight different Bibles
and books and things so thank you Mr
Shear I would concur with representative
Mills on that
and as I try and get out of my house
from my wife I'm going to throw you an
atta boy so thank you
uh We've we've concluded our work for
today we will come back I believe the
hour was 10 o'clock on Friday and I'll
see you roaming the Halls tomorrow in